it has been five days since the World
Cup concluded in Qatar and most teams
have now safely returned home but the
status of Iran's national football team
remains unclear many of you will
remember these images of Iran refusing
to sing their country's national anthem
ahead of their opener against England it
was an act of solidarity with protests
back home in Iran over the death of Masa
amini who died in police custody but
what happened to those players when they
returned home
well joining me to answer that question
and more is Kasra medical an Iranian
Taekwondo athlete who has been living in
Exile here in Berlin khasra thanks so
much for joining us
um so can you tell us what happened to
the Iranian football team after they
returned home well actually nothing
happened to them because they couldn't
protest and they couldn't support the
Iranian people very well so we were mad
at them but it seems like they were
under the pressure from the Islamic
regime and the Islamic regime monitored
them so so if they could do something
else it's going to be dangerous for them
and for their families that because I
think they couldn't do something else
and they could they couldn't do it more
and it's not just football you yourself
have experienced firsthand what it's
like can you tell us a little bit more
about how dangerous the situation is for
athletes exactly I remember a few weeks
ago was a wrestling tournament in U.S
and the Iranian national team was there
and when the reporter asked them what's
going on in Iran and how do you think
about the situation in Iran so it seems
like the answer is already explained to
them and they just say yeah we are
athlete here and we are here just to
compete nothing else so many athletes
have have been already arrested and some
of them like Muhammad Mahdi karami and
Amira azadani are facing the execution
so extremely dangerous and choosing
their words very carefully I know that
you're also in touch with many athletes
who are back home can you tell me what
they've been telling you yeah I'm in
touch with many athletes especially the
members of a national team and many of
them mentioned that
they got a message or an old theme at
home from the sport Federation or a
security escort in the sport federations
who can control the athletes that if
they do something if they protest if
they even share something on the social
media platforms it can be dangerous for
them and definitely they cannot continue
their sport carrier so the Islamic
regime knows well that the athletes they
have a special social status in Iran
that's because they were under the
pressure and the government want to
control them to finally control the
people and protesters it's really
interesting what do you think the
Iranian government through all of this
is actually trying to achieve so in fact
Islamic regime is afraid of the unity of
the Iranian people and the Islamic
regime continues execution and torture
for 40 years and they have a clear
message that we don't care who you are
if you are an athlete a champion a hero
or even a normal person we don't give
you any opportunity to do or say
something against our ideology that's
because we believe the only solution is
the revolution